der klimawandel fällt aus wir sind alle
gerettet denn seit dieser woche tagt
unser neues klima kabinett also ganz
ehrlich gesagt sind dass sie sehen es
einfach die üblichen minister nur die
müssen jetzt halt manchmal nachsitzen
siebte stunde welt retten bei frau dr
merkel und zeit wird's deutschland
verfehlt sämtliche klimaziele mit
karacho was hat dieses klima kabinett
denn jetzt so für pläne einen ersten
überblick ist es erstmal er in der
nächsten sitzung gemein wo wir einmal
uns einen überblick über alle bereiche
auch verschaffen aber wir wollen auch
nach diesem ersten überblick nochmal
genauer entscheiden wann wir was
diskutieren also genau gesagt wer wann
genau wie genau was genau wir wollen da
uns einen ersten überblick verschaffen
ich brauche mehr details
durchaus
frau schulze ja warum
super blick verschaffen ist ja nie
verkehrt und das alte ja auch nicht
deutschland muss ja seinen co2 ausstoß
bis 2030 nur um 55 prozent reduzieren
das klimaschutzgesetz der brokkoli zwar
wegen streit seit wochen auf eis aber
hey da fragen wir jetzt ein klima
kabinett ja tagsüber sind sie ganz
normale minister aber bei vollmond
verwandeln sie sich in das klima
kabinett
peter altmaier total knuffiger
wirtschaftsminister doch wenn man ihn
nach mitternacht füttert wird dazu
mister methan seine superkraft ist
biogas julia klöckner verwandelt sich im
volumen als junge weinkönigin in einen
bottich riesling gefallen hat sie
seitdem immer gute laune finanzminister
olaf scholz alias das valium hält so
lange vorträge über die schwarze null
bis sogar das co2 in der atmosphäre ein
trend und natürlich der wichtigste an
die steuer wird zu doktor diesel
er hat die einmalige fähigkeit seine
eigenen gedanken zu lesen aber da ist
nichts was die mannschaft
toll
habe ich endlich ein klima kabinett
nächste sitzung im mai mit denen wird
alles gut ebenfalls diese woche am
übrigens die demonstrierenden schüler
von friday is for future erstmals sehr
konkrete forderung gestellt
können sie nachlesen in der neuen
bibliothek die jungen menschen verlangen
die jungen menschen verlangt von der
groko unter anderem bis ende des jahres
ein viertel der deutschen
kohlekraftwerke abzuschalten sehr gute
idee kinder nur leider können die worte
bis ende des jahres und groko nie im
selben satz vorkommen ist so
entsprechend frustriert klingen die
jungen menschen von den erwachsen wird
keinen schritt in richtung konkretes
handeln getan wir haben genug von lob
ohne taten das ist dermaßen falsch und
verlogen
das ist für uns entsetzlich also der ton
wenn erwachsene ein scheiße finden dann
kinder die recht haben was denken die
denn wenn man die sind doch alle
ferngesteuert diese plagen kann alles
nicht wahr sein ja ekelhaft gut
informierte pratzen eine zeit lang fand
die politik das ja ganz niedlich mit
ihren demos aber irgendwann muss auch
mal schluss sein
und deshalb sage ich den schülerinnen
und schülern wenn ihr am nachmittag am
freitag demonstriert dann komme ich auch
zu euch und ständig neben euch bei der
demonstration das soll aber keine sorgt
dass du dich daneben stellt
ja
was stelle ich mich daneben
da sagen viele schüler dann lieber
erderwärmung christian überlasst den
klimaschutz mal lieber den profis
lindner führt immer noch einen kreuzzug
gegen das schuleschwänzen denn er ist
damals wirklich wahnsinnig gern zur
schule gegangen wenn man in der schule
sitzt und man sitzt seine zeit ab weiß
dass man telefonieren den kunden
besuchen oder arbeit erledigen müsste
dann kommt man sich so vor als sei die
zeit durch den schredder gelaufen so ein
süßer jungen was ist aus ihm geworden
traurig traurig lindner ist gegen feste
co2 einsparziele er sagt zitat man kann
doch gar nicht wissen wo wann welche
technologischen quantensprung gelingt
wir haben richtig verstand mit anderen
worten wir brauchen keinen kohleausstieg
weil bestimmt bald was erfunden wird
hier jetzt im buchhandel jetzt neu dinge
um die sich nicht mehr kümmern müssen
weil es wird ja bestimmt bald irgendwas
erfunden
kündigen sie noch heute ihren job sehr
wahrscheinlich findet bald eine tolle
app die ihr konto immer wieder auffällt
wenn es er ist nur idioten bringe noch
den müll runter
bald wird er antike drohne erfunden die
das für sie erledigt zwtl putzen wozu
christian lindner ist sich sicher die
nahe zukunft er findet jemand etwas viel
besseres szene und vor allem kaufen sie
auf keinen fall dieses buch morgen
schreibt bestimmt einer ein viel
besseres
ja irgendwann wird das erfunden
er meint das ernst
ja
ist bei ihnen zu hause bestimmt auch so
diese frei disco future demos die ja
weitergehen lösen heftige diskussionen
aus besonders in der elterngeneration
tragen wir es aus mit albrecht humboldt
von der cdu potsdam und von den
kreuzberger grünen dort hausten
geschiedene kölling dingeldein
hallo liebe zu sehen von mir jetzt
gleich mal direkt eine provokante these
in your face schule schwänzen ist okay
fand ich schon als schülerin
ich hatte früher eine oberstufe ganz oft
so ein bauchfreie t shirt anders stand
ruf ich steh auf schwänzen
aber die jungs 100 klasse leider ein
völlig falscher weg recht aber für
andere geschichte was also warum werden
hier plötzlich schwänze schwenzer heilig
gesprochen die kinder sind doch total
indoktriniert von links-grün versifften
helikopter müttern wie der da ja sie
schleppen ihre narben sogar mit ins
studio
sorry der wahrheit vormittag bei der
demo ja und danach ist ja immer total
überdreht der sören gandalf da lass ich
ihn uni anna leenen jurys kinder wollen
mir erzählen wie ich zu leben habe was
glauben die denn das sind kinder die
sind viel kleiner als ich kommen damit
ihren fakten und regelrechten argumenten
arschlöcher
die sollen verdammt nochmal jeder
normale kinder sachen machen wie wir
früher verstecken spielen frösche
aufblasen verkaufen keine ahnung
kindersachen also ich find ja landed
wortkind hat war total abwertendes ja
ihr hattet sind doch keine kinder den
syrern gangart zum beispiel den hab ich
vor über zwei jahren abgestellt
darf man nicht zu früh machen das muss
man die impfenden wissen viele nicht was
also ich verstehe überhaupt nicht was
die alte lammert und ich habe die
schnauze voll von renitenten plagen
jetzt haben die diese woche forderungen
veröffentlicht seit wann dürfen kinder
was fordern alte regel kinder soll man
sehen aber nicht hören so forderung da
gehen wir mal schnell mit dem rotstift
durch also wir wollen den kohleausstieg
bis 2030 das interessiert doch keine sau
nur noch erneuerbare energien bis 2035
am arsch netto null in der treibhaus
bilanz selber netto null einführung
einer co2 steuer das wort gibt's gar
nicht reichlich durch 5+ durchgefallen
setzen ps er stinkt ihr blöden kleinen
öko stalin ist also ich könnte das
einfach nur noch traurig lieber friday
kids von mir kriegt ihr stadtmann note
eine kleine sonne
hat der souvenir mal was richtig super
gemacht
mein sohn ist übrigens hochbegabt denn
sieht man daran dass sei ganz schlechte
zensuren schreibt also ich find die idee
muss auf jeden fall super und wir sind
doch unterdessen an dem punkt wo die
kinder wie erwachsene argumentieren und
erwachsene wie kinder trotzphase bitte
wieso bin ich kindisch denn ich darauf
hinweise dass chinesen viel mehr co2
ausblasen als wir
sollen sie doch erst mal was machen ich
war das doch gar nicht mit dem co2 das
ist für unfair
die chinesen dürfen alles und nicht das
nichts
da co2 steuern wie soll denn
funktionieren ohne dass die wirtschaft
ab packt da fällt einem surren dingsbums
nix ein
wieso die schweden haben so eine steuer
seit 1990 seitdem sind die emissionen
gesunken und die wirtschaft ist
gewachsen
[Applaus]
[Musik]
ich habe die schnauze voll ich fahr nach
hause wir mit euren scheiß fakten
superserie ein echter wir beten
gemeinsam für klima- oder ghetto faust
genau du fliegst ostern wieder zusammen
achtsamkeit seminar nach indien hat ja
nach indien kommt man halt nicht mit dem
fahrrad du bist so nach syrien
du kannst dir deine blöden dinkel
auflauf heute selber an die mikrowelle
schlimm ist also guten tag könnte ich
sie für ein abo des heute show you tube
kanal als begeistern schließt gefälligst
ein abo ab sofort